[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans les 7 8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
rugby désirent monter officiellement en
fédérale 2 les plaisirs oies sont sortis
vainqueurs de leur duel contre
marcq-en-baroeul en 16e de finale de
fédérale 3 la réaction de l'entraîneur
jean mi sita sud dans ce magazine
baseball les cougars de
montigny-le-bretonneux ont réussi ce
week-end a remporté à domicile leur deux
matches contre les ducks de
saint-just-saint-rambert 9 à 4 et 10 à 9
de victoire importante dans la course
aux premières places plus d'informations
à suivre
équitation victor lévesque sera l'une
des têtes d'affiché française des jeux
olympiques de 2024
à seulement 18 ans le sportif originaire
des yvelines a déjà été double
vice-champion d'europe en 2015 et 2016
et quatre fois champion de france nous
lui avons posé trois questions
gros plan à présent sur les principaux
résultats du week-end dans le
département
[Musique]
on commence donc ce magazine par du
rugby fait plaisir a écrit sur lequel
l'une des plus belles pages de son
histoire les plaisirs au n ont pas
tremblé en 16e de finale retour à marcq
en baroeul pour valider leur ticket pour
la fédérale 2 deux ans après l'avoir
quittée vainqueur 31 16 au match aller
des seizièmes de finale plaisir s'est
inclinée 20 à 12
à l'extérieur une défaite anecdotique
puisque plaisir domine son adversaire
sur l'ensemble des deux matches
au nombre de points inscrits on écoute
l'entraîneur jean missile était
évidemment très heureux on l'aurait
souhaité mais avec modération comme il
se doit toujours aujourd'hui je suis
heureux de ce qu'on a pu accomplir parce
que c'est très difficile l'analyse de
supporter tout ça va être un combat qu'a
fait ça on quitte le ballon ovale pour
parler de baseball en première division
les cougars de menti aux bretonnants ont
réussi ce week-end a remporté à domicile
leur deux matches contre les ducks de
saint-just-saint-rambert 9 à 4 et 10 à 9
2 victoire importante dans la course aux
premières places et pourquoi pas au
titre de champion de france
roma respini pour le montage les cougars
rugissent de plaisir les zinnias montant
remporté ce dimanche 14 mai une victoire
au forceps dans les derniers instants
contre saint-just-saint-rambert 10 à 9
un résultat qui s'ajoutent à une
démonstration dans la matinée de
l'équipe 9 à 4 face aux auvergnats
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que j'ai senti
une petite baisse deuxième match il a
fallu remettre toutes les toute la
troupe en route
et puis il a fallu le déclin petit
déclencheur une frappe qui emmène une
autre frappe de l'autre côté on a une
équipe qui a commencé à faiblir à la
septième manche 8e manche et on a pris
le dessus de victoire importante dans la
course aux premières places les signé
mon teint sont pour le moment quatrième
du championnat sur huit équipes engagées
on va rester serein on va garder la tête
froide aient encore beaucoup de matches
la saison ne fait que commencer et on va
on va prendre les matches un par un et
on garde le même objectif c'est rester
en milieu de tableau
pour réaliser cet objectif montigny le
bretonneux a effectué un recrutement en
adéquation avec ses ambitions ces
derniers jours deux japonais
rejoint l'effectif et lyoto et choi sur
le terrain aussi ils sont là ils font
leur job enfin on sent que c'est des
gars qui ont une expérience et qui nous
amène ça et c'est vraiment important
pour l'équipe mon premier but cette
année est de gagner le championnat de
france
personnellement j'aimerais faire une
bonne saison pour jouer aux états unis
et deux japonais sur une nouvelle fois
sur la feuille de match pour le
déplacement de montigny le bretonneux à
clermont ferrand le dimanche 21 mai une
équipe que les cougars ont dévoré au
match aller cyclisme sur piste à présent
la coupe de france à l'américaine était
organisée à ce mercredi au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
par le comité ile de france 70 équipes
issues de 13 comités régionaux sur sont
inscrits pour disputer l'épreuve pascal
josèphe pour le montage
ce mercredi 10 mai lever le double
national de saint quentin en yvelines a
accueilli l'une des compétitions les
plus spectaculaires du cyclisme sur
piste la course à l'américaine alors
l'américaine c'est une épreuve par
équipes de deux coureurs
sachant que c'est une épreuve de run et
donc que les coureurs font en deux ou
trois tours ça là ça dépend l allure où
ça roule et passe le relais à leurs
collègues
et puis tous les plusieurs dizaines de
tours y allait y aller classement où les
gens doivent prendre des points pour
cette seconde coupe de france organisée
dans la structure 70 équipes issues de
13 comités régionaux se sont inscrits
peu ce qu'on peut donner son avis tu
savoir si on peut surprendre dans deux
catégories ou dans le club c'est
important d'être ici parce que l'on
montre un peu pour déjà les couleurs de
l'eau vient de ronald la maîtrise y
rouler sur un aussi beau vélodrome je
suis quand même très content d'y être
sur la piste les cours n'ont pas hésité
à jouer des coudes pour remporter la
victoire au péril de leur sécurité
y'a pas toujours la place pour tout le
monde et des fois il ya des coureurs qui
veulent passer en dessous alors que par
par code on doit passer au dessus donc
voilà s'affrontent notamment chez les
jeux ne sont pas encore très très
habitué la difficulté l'américaine c'est
qu'il faut voir loin et c'est compliqué
de voir loin devant rouler vite
les cours qui ont réussi à tenir sur
leurs vélos ont réalisé les meilleurs
chronos sont qualifiés pour les futurs
championnats de france 2010 est la
compétition se déroulera cet été on
prend à présent la direction d'elancourt
la fédération française de football
américain s'est associé avec la national
football academy organise un camp
d'entraînement dans la commune 90
joueurs venus de la région parisienne
ont participé à ces deux jours au
complexe sportif europe
les sportifs ont notamment été coachée
par darin cela qu ancien quarterback de
l'université central florida dans les
années 80 il a également entraîné 40000
coach athlètes à travers les états unis
on écoute les réactions micro de nicolas
landry pour le joueur c'est de là
c'est leur présenter une nouvelle façon
de voir les choses de leur présenter des
des techniques et des tactiques qu'ils
auraient pas l'occasion de voir
forcément et qu'ils améliorent surtout
leur lecture or il ya beaucoup de
potentiel de grandes capacités très
attentifs et du talent dans ce groupe
c'est un vrai plaisir de faire
progresser on ouvre une page boxe le 5
mai dernier l'élan courtois adila
hamouma 10 a réussi à reconquérir son
titre de champion d'europe des poids
super-moyens en terrassant en espagne
l'ibérique mariano hilario après cette
victoire le boxeur de 36 ans déjà les
yeux rivés sur ses prochains objectifs
notamment sur une couronne mondiale en
écoute le sportif au micro de camille
lambert
prochaine étape je pense qu'on mettra
peut-être le titre en le titre européen
en jeu qu'on leur met une fois en jeu
pour pouvoir le faire dans le sol
français
le faire en france ça serait un de même
un plaisir fou andromède mettre la
ceinture européenne en france et puis
ensuite attaqué directement au niveau du
monde
je vous propose maintenant de partir
dans une galaxie lointaine très
lointaine dans ce magazine c'est une
première en ile de france un championnat
interclubs de combat au sabre laser
était organisée ce dimanche 14 mai au
centre sportif les pyramides de
voisins-le-bretonneux au programme des
combats en individuel des tournois
techniques et des combats chorégraphiés
une vingtaine de participants venus
principalement des yvelines a participé
à l'événement en écoute le président de
l'académie de sabre laser et
organisateur cvec géo était au micro de
nicolas landry on leur apprend à
maîtriser le sabre laser comme une
véritable arme parce que c'est pas un
jouet qu'ils ont entre les mains c'est
un objet avec une lame en polycarbonate
qui est plus solides canaux subit donc
pour les enfants qu'ils ont un petit peu
fou fou ça leur permet un petit peu de
canaliser
laure leur joie et leur bonne humeur on
va dire et pour les adultes
ça permet de re découvrir un nouveau
sport un nouveau art martial un petit
peu différent un mot d'équitation à
présent son nom ne vous dit peut-être
rien mais ce jeune cavalier de vrais
revenus devenir l'une des têtes
d'affiché françaises aux jeux olympiques
de 2024 à seulement à 18 ans le sportif
originaire des yvelines à ceux déjà été
double vice championne d'europe en 2015
et 2016 et quatre fois champion france
des résultats qui ont poussé le comité
régional d'équitation d'ile-de-france à
le désigner
ambassadeur pour les jo de 2024 je parle
bien sûr de victor lévesque nous lui
avons posé trois questions
j'habite dans les yvelines depuis je
suis tout petit et j'ai également mes
écuries les écuries et qui paul sont
situés dans le 78 donc c'est une région
que je connais particulièrement bien et
que j'apprécie je m'entraîne dans mes
écuries à lecture et qui paul qui à la
boissière école on a la chance d'avoir
dans les yvelines notamment la fois de
rambouillet qui me permet d'entraîner le
conte de mes chevaux et avoir un
environnement particulièrement agréable
pour le bien-être de tout le monde
c'est donc la fédération qui s'occupe de
mon sport
voilà je fais du concours complet depuis
je suis tout petit j'ai la chance
d'avoir était assez jeunes intégrés dans
les stages équipe de france notamment
que pour cause de la fédération ces
stages permettent de détecter les jeunes
comme moi ça m'a permis notamment de
concourir des belles épreuves dès mon
plus jeune âge notamment les choper à de
france des championnats d'europe
je pense que l'objectif de la fédération
c'est d'accompagner évidemment les
sportifs de haut niveau sont déjà guéris
mais également la jeune génération et
afin de coupler tout le monde est de
tirer tout le monde vers le haut donc
voilà la fédération mal mon pagne depuis
que je suis jeune c'est une vraie fierté
et j'essaie de leur rendre honneur sur
chaque compétition
les jeux olympiques c'est un rêve pour
tout le monde évidemment je pense que
pour tous les sportifs
pour moi c'est un rêve depuis que je
suis tout petit progressivement ça
devient un objectif paris est candidat
pour les jeux olympiques et
paralympiques en 2024
c'est une magnifique candidature c'est
évidemment un rêve pour moi après voilà
j'y pense évidemment tout le temps mais
il faut savoir être raisonnable j'ai
encore énormément de choses à apprendre
j'espère que paris les orages parce que
paris a toutes les cartes en main et
j'espère que je pourrai à concourir sur
le parc du château de versailles
la commission du cio était justement
aujourd'hui en visite dans les yvelines
pour voir les différencie du département
concerné par le dossier parisien des jo
de 2024
comme on peut le voir sur ces images
twitté par les responsables de la ffc le
maire de versailles saint quentin en
yvelines
les officiels se sont rendus au
vélodrome et à versailles pour voir les
sites
le verdict sera rendu en septembre à
lima au pérou
on passe maintenant à notre rubrique
agenda
[Musique]
on commence à ta gens d'à part de la
boxe en vous la non sur tv fil 78 depuis
plusieurs semaines l'un des plus grands
combats de la carrière de marvin petit
double champion de france se disputera
ce jeudi 18 mai le sportif élan courtois
défiera au cirque d'hiver de paris
l'espagnol ray robes et santana pour la
ceinture de l'union européenne le combat
était initialement prévu en janvier
dernier mail ibérique avait annulé le
combat deux jours avant l'événement si
vous voulez le soutenir reste quelques
places à la vente en espérant que le
combat se déroule cette fois-ci on
continue à parler de boxe dans cet
agenda avec le premier combat
professionnel tant attendu de libye noah
tony yoka les sportifs originaires de
chanteloup les vignes champion olympique
des poids super lourds défiera le 2 juin
au palais des sports de paris
l'américain travis clark un adversaire
qui a disputé douze combats pour 12
victoires dont 8 avant la limite
dans la même soirée le verrier roi ahmed
el moussaoui combattre à lui pour un
combat international des poids mi-moyens
contre un adversaire qui reste encore à
déterminer
il y aura du football également ce
week-end avec la danone nations cup
l'équivalent de la coupe du monde des
jeunes âgés de 10 à 12 ans l'une des
étapes françaises de cette 18e édition
est programmée ce samedi 20 mai sur la
pelouse du stade bauer à saint-ouen
trois équipes des yvelines ont été
sélectionnés pour participer à
l'événement le fc mantois 78 l'ice
poissy et versailles les clubs
présenteront des effectifs de 12 joueurs
ou huit titulaires et quatre en plaçant
les meilleures formations valideront
leur ticket pour participer à la finale
nationale qui se déroulera à bordeaux le
11 juin approchant on jouera également
sur les pelouses du championnat
excellence guyancourt saint-quentin
recevra l'équipe 2 de versailles en
match en retard
une rencontre capitale dans la lutte aux
premières places légumes courtois sont
pour l'instant troisièmes du classement
à deux points des versailles et si vous
voulez assister à ce choc la partie se
jouera ce mercredi soir à 20 heures au
stade maurice baquet c'est enfin 68
sport merci de l'avoir suivi très belle
soirée sur tv fil 78
[Musique]